chest up chin up squat I just really
give up for a life control said I can't
live like this is too frightening it not
to be able to see it's not how I had
envisioned my life to be learning about
powerlifting gave me an opportunity to
focus on something I didn't know that I
would become a champion one day I just
wanted to be able to do something with
my life that would make a difference
[Music]
my name is Charles King I'm 69 years old
and I'm a blind athlete in the sport of
palate in 1977 I spent a few months in
military after coming back I was able to
get a job with a construction company
and the mother of my children was
pregnant with twins I was happy about my
life but in 1989 came I was I
have a nerve disease I couldn't work so
my hopes were shattered at that point
something inside of me snap I gave up on
life and went to the streets of
Philadelphia to be homeless I got down
with winos and alcoholics
unfortunately also learned about drugs
out there crack cocaine I just continued
to go down spiral and spiral and spout
and not Karen in 1996 I was drunk and I
just laid down when I woke up the next
morning the police came by and it says
okay listen it's too cold for you to be
out hit and when I went to get up I
couldn't stand up couldn't feel my legs
I thought blindness was the worst thing
that can happen to me
Shh until that frost bit that was
frightening
you guys took me to the VA hospital
because he had known as a veteran I was
in the hospital for 17 days before cast
and I'm Ellen
they said the VA could offer me services
first of all I just want to welcome
everyone it's amazing that you're all
here today I want to take this
opportunity for Charles to tell his
story good afternoon fellow vets and
blinded veterans how you're feeling
today home they sent me to drug and
alcohol rehabilitation and I met other
veterans who are blind and learning to
live slowly I began to feel good about
myself as a human being in spite of not
being able to see and it felt good and
my wife and I we got married in 1999 and
the next year started attending
Community College and while I was in
college my daughter died
she had developmental issues the pain of
my daughter died was really brutal a few
years later I get diagnosed with
prostate cancer and diabetes no I'm
looking up God what is wrong with you
you know I'm only one man
this is just too much to take I just
didn't have any joy I needed something
more of my life
[Music]
the VA offered me the chance to go to
the Olympic Training Center to see what
time people turn and I met with these
other behind athletes and I became
impressed by what they were doing lose
the sparkle life came to me well I want
to try this I like to do powerlifting I
[Music]
started training and competing at sixty
years of age for powerlifting they're
three lifts which you have to make the
squat the bent fresh and they did lift
being totally blind is very difficult
your site balances you
it took my coach eight months to teach
me how to squat the most important part
is making sure that your form technique
and balance are all in line with your
mind I've had a lot of successes I won
first place at the national blind
powerlifting Championships
I set all records at the world
championship games and the Olympiad
games for blind athletes I managed to
come in fourth place
I'd like to compete the national and
world competition until I'm 80 but I'd
also like to be able to be a
spokesperson or advocate for other blind
athletes who need help
what does triumph triumph triumph for me
isn't those medals upstairs triumph for
me isn't having my name and our record
books
triumph Amir's I've learned how to love
myself no matter what life throws
[Music]
[Music]